[Music]
mike tyson raves in full bloom captured
the art of fighting
the hollywood reporter says it's mallet
meet scorsese
in full bloom available now on amazon
prime video
i can make forty thousand a year stretch
out yeah i bet now but when you were
fighting
you were pretty loosey-goosey with money
right oh my god elephant in the room but
you know
[ __ ] that's why that's what i'm saying
the next thing i see this girl is
forgive me god why did you make me like
what's up guys i'm brendan schaub
co-host in hot boxing
with mike tyson and i'm mike tyson and
we have such a lustrous guest today
francis argano talk to us champ the new
ufc heavyweight champion of the entire
world
what's that 7.7 billion people what's
the world's population seven
eight billion people seven eight billion
people
you could beat in a fair fight
the children the babies the girls the
baddest man on the planet yeah straight
up
on the planet wow what a pleasure to be
introducing by
the big mike himself you know
there's no time to be humble right now
champ be the great champion
thank you everybody tell us about the
feeling of capturing the champions oh
man
it's awesome i remember being there uh
at that moment i can't explain how it
i mean i mean you might know it but i
don't know how to explain that feeling
did they show your hometown back home
yeah
people understand have you seen it mike
yeah it's great i
i have even a better a better video uh
because like we have people there
they were filming and uh when you see
that you just go
crazy they were gonna they lost their
mind not
oh yeah because of the scene be the
great fighter you didn't beat a tomato
can uh bomb you be the great fighter you
know he's great
to teach you before we even call him
great is almost an understatement i mean
something
you know steve grace of all time yeah
like there's argument for that
as well
think about your first fight like most
of those shots you landed would put
anybody out yeah yeah he stuck with it
even the first round for this fight yeah
like he was
eating them and just look walk walk like
nothing
i knew he was in trouble when he
attempted that take down
and you sprawled and brawled and then
got his back and seat belt and started
punching
oh it's about to be a long night for
steve france learned how to wrestle oh
yeah i was ready
i'm like you know um what happened
in 2018 can't happen anymore
like i have to be ready for this
that had to happen for this to happen
correct yep
that don't if that don't happen you
don't come in because because i don't
think you're ready that's true yeah
that's true yeah cause is it fair to say
like if you would have won that first
time
i don't know because i you know you look
at the potential matchups you have in
the future which we'll get into
but i don't think you your legacy would
be cemented like it's going to be now
because
that first fight you know you you needed
that
just not just my legacy like uh even my
fight iq
my understanding of the game i mean he
was just like four years and a half
since when i get into mma so i had a lot
of
doubt like an answer question that i was
i remember being there i was like asking
myself a lot of questions
yeah and i get there just after uh that
fight
right there i understood that i needed
this
i mean it wasn't like the best outcome
what i was
expected but i knew that uh from this
fight
i'm gonna go far i kind of like uh
circle the be
the uh fight and understand
like how he works now so i'm gonna be
ready
for the next time and to be honest i
think like if he wasn't about that fight
as you said i wouldn't be here now
because uh even if i would have win that
fight
later on down the road yes i would have
fallen because yeah
there was a lot of uh and for have you
noticed that most fighters don't
understand
no i understood that like right away
like
i'm like okay he's sad that i lost but
at the meantime there's a lot of good
thing in this like
i didn't have that experience i have a
lot of holes
in my game that i uh need to fill up and
that
allowed me to really understand what was
that and i'm like
okay from here i'll gain that experience
i have all the
answer for the question that i had and
uh you know
moving on i gonna know what i'm putting
myself into
and that's why i like walking into this
fight i knew
like what what could possibly happen
what could be the worst thing
uh to happen like i was ready like okay
doesn't matter what happened i will be
here i will
have the answer for that and you're also
calm cool and collected like
like in previous fights it always worked
because i think your longest fight
for previously this like a minute 12 or
minute 11 so you're starching dudes
and i i was like man let's see if
francis has
you know if his iq's gotten higher
because you did rock stipe and i was go
here he goes and you stay calm
collected and just weathered you know
just you didn't rush in like an
inexperienced guy would do exactly and
that's what's scary to me
exactly that's terrifying and that's
what i'm talking about like gaining
experience from the last five years
because when you look
the last fight that's exactly what i did
like
after a punch i was just walking through
him like
yep you know and you can't walk to a
champion like that no way
and i'm like no there's something then
after that fight i went back
washed his tips i'm like this guy's
stuff you can't just
go there expect to just walk through him
no he's not gonna fall you know and uh
for this time everything was just about
to be
calm like collect stay composed
take your time like you have 25 minutes
yes sir
you're gonna you have to manage that you
know if you go
crazy you're going to lose your uh gas
tank
in like maybe one round that's what's
steeping what it wants what about
what about the on the other five rounds
yeah you should get there
so i'm like okay we have to spend like
equally stay in the same gas in the same
level
yes sir and see how it plays out and uh
yeah and what's your wrestling coach's
name i trained my as trainer
stream and sometimes eric or
dennis who yeah i think it's eric
because going into the fight
i said and i think he got to your coach
because he was like what is shob talking
about because i said
you know everyone's like france francis
so much better friends so much better
all i said was
we don't know and it's not his fault but
he's been starching everybody in
those those four previous fights his
longest fight was a minute 11. he starts
everyone so i said
we the verdict's not out if his
wrestling's any better
that's all i said i think he was like
what the hell shob
and then after this fight i went holy
[ __ ] his wrestling's way better
they were right you know what i'm saying
yeah and working to this fight i know
that
there might be some trap for stephen
because
like if he he might watch he watched my
fight again uh
jesus and see the way that i rushed into
that fight yes and he was expecting me
to
do the same thing i'm like this guy
hasn't changed he's gonna do the same
thing correct so he was there like
waiting for me
yeah i'm like uh come on but then that's
what he did
that's why right he he landed a decent
shot and he was like oh [ __ ] i got him
then he rushed in and then that's where
you clipped them with that left
hook yeah because even when he landed
that right hand
what went in in my mind was like damn
you're doing something wrong
because i knew we've been working on and
i knew that
the steepest step back uh back right
is his burst punch yep and that's what
he caught verdon with the first time
correct that's how he got it
yeah that's how he gets his bed so uh
when i get that right hand on my face
i'm like damn you did something wrong
recon
resettle came down and uh collect and
then
he just run he was just running to me
with his hand like this
like the roses he was doing what you did
against rosenstein he was like rushing
it
was just like then i'm like where are
you going
fighting is interesting yeah man yeah
see people
it's just awesome [ __ ] mike
now that he's champ and obviously you
know france has a squad now
and one of the most famous guys on the
planet and you know this better than
anyone
is there is there things like traps you
should watch out for
like it's just because when you're
ranked number one it's just it's it's
different when you're chant
absolutely you know you know mike
there's traffic yeah but you know he's
this guy's definitely just going to stay
hungry because he made
he could he learned from the first fight
with um the champ
yep right you learn from the first fight
you you know
you are him you can be beat you know you
came into that
reality before you know you thought you
couldn't be beaten you got beat by this
guy
so that makes you even a better fight
fighter it should make you a better
fighter
should make you rise to the occasion
because you should know there's guys out
there
hungry just like you now guys who were
afraid of you when you were contenders
but now you're champion they're not
afraid of you no more they want to eat
you alive
isn't that something yeah everybody's
afraid of you when you're the contender
but when you're the champion that's
which change
they have to eat because you have the
best yeah
when you you're the contender you got
the bag you get nothing for them
yeah but when you got the bag what the
rest of the child
that developed mean hungry people baby
yeah and you look at
who could potentially be next obviously
the main narrative is jon jones which as
a fan
is the number one blockbuster fight the
ufc can make
but the only hiccup with that is john
wants to
receive compensation to fight a monster
in you well he should
he should he should agree i mean nothing
wrong with that uh
everybody in this position would like to
have a compensation
i mean uh basically a guy like jones
he's been around for very long and been
doing
uh this sport and this company grow so
yeah
uh i think there's nothing wrong about
that
but um once again i don't know what the
deal is
yeah i mean you know so um i would like
that fight to happen
is that the number one if you if if they
gave you a list and it's
john definitely be there number one
really
it's gone right like uh john is john
john john definitely but um
at this point um we don't know what's
going to happen so
what do you think mike john jones
francis how do you say that
i think it's going to happen and
ludicrous if it doesn't happen
right because this this this right now
it all comes down to money right now
mm-hmm
you know how can they do this they both
under contract do we do it under the ufc
or do we do it under this
and pay you know what do you do how do
you do this stuff
really you just really just need to put
up the money to please jon jones and
to defend jon jones here you know he is
the pound for pound
best fighter on the planet he's
undefeated for a reason i said 10
million
nothing if he if he takes it what do you
say 20 25
that's still for a big fight like that
he could say hey maybe that's nothing
but you know fighters have to understand
they can in a corporation like
legends only league our fighters are
like our partners
you know it's not like we own you and
you got to go by our rules there's no
rules you fight you get paid you get
your back and everything's over
and we everybody get our money we go to
separate banks yep
you know no one's anybody's slaves oh no
in france how do you feel vegas odds
came out i'm sure you don't pay
attention to this but they have john
or they have john as the for the first
time his career as an underdog
they have you as the favorite which it
might create that's a little surprising
i think it'd be like maybe even money or
maybe you
but it's like i think they have you as
like uh that's that listen
no why is that way because they want
money they want to know because the odds
are
they're gonna they're gonna work on this
they're gonna make this a david goliath
thing
and for the first time you know
john you know everybody's looking as a
big guy picking on a little guy
and john is gonna be favorites and stuff
you know people
the fans the people not just the people
the thinking the sympathetic people he's
fighting the big giant and so
we're going to root for him you know
american story we beat the odds and he's
going to have a lot of people
he's going to have a lot of the betting
odds it's a different animal than stipe
right
frank francis like as far as john
compared to someone outside of the bed
for sure people yeah the public you're
talking about the public
doesn't make sense yeah that makes sense
yeah
that makes sense but when you look up
that when you look at that match up
francis i'll see a different fight than
steep bay right
yeah john john jones has uh definitely
has more
uh tools in his pocket than his tv
but i'm not sure if he's tough as steep
at all that's a fair point
i think too one of the reasons the odds
are like that
is i went back and watched jon jones
last few fights his last three fights
yeah he gets hit he gets hit and i don't
know if he's just not getting not have
to fight the watch
but those are his last three i can't go
back we look at him
but um he's always capable in a
situation like this he's capable to rise
above the kingship
this is not the last three guys that's
what i think yeah correct me that's what
i think
i i think i think he couldn't get up for
those fights those guys aren't big names
so he's kind of fighting to their level
still one but with a guy like you he
knows he has to watch his p's and q's
yeah he's not because you take one shot
from francis
the fight's over he knows that so he has
to put
more work into it right than his
he's just an interesting guy um john
jones he's bait too he's creative he's
tall
have you met him in person he's huge we
are mems the same size
that's what people don't realize they
think john's is smart john's huge no
it's just not small
yeah his iq man you know this like his
fight iq is
nuts john's the he's not the most
athletic he's the smartest fighter
that's why john's so good and that's why
and i'm not um
saying i'm not um saying it's good that
boy he live his life he could live his
life the way he wants
but um that's why sometimes he he slacks
off he's just too good
yeah but i know francis is a friend from
the first steeple fight
never underestimate the other opponents
absolutely
um love for glory
[Music]
francis because you were just starching
everybody so it's like
and you don't have a ton of experience
so then you get to stipe and you land
those big shots on him and he didn't
back down
you know what i'm saying so it's like if
you had that before you got the steep
bay
it might have been a different animal
because your power's so insane so it's
like you touch guys they go to sleep
so um i see i saw that fight how i
approached that fight i think something
was wrong i i was
like on a lot of pressure on everything
you know i have
um i have to figure out everything on my
own and
in a very short period of time and never
been in that
uh never been that level of fighting you
know i was kind of
i didn't know what i was putting myself
into how desperation was
affecting me you know then when i get
there
i don't know it was i wasn't me like my
feelings
even during the fight week i would i
didn't feel
anything at all like it was so weird so
i look at that fight even how i
approached that fight
i was the guy was looking like me but i
didn't recognize the style i'm like
what the hell is doing but actually that
was
exactly what i did you know yeah so even
before that fight if you look at oh
my fight if you watch my previous fight
before
before the first tp fight i don't rush
in fight like that yeah that was the
only one yeah like
then that's why i was even more
concerned like okay
why am i what went wrong you know from
there
and that imp affected me
so much and i didn't realize that until
i get into the directly with fight
then i get there uh i think i was in my
mind
still fighting stipe you know that fight
was so weird
like people just see how he plays out
outside but
nobody knows how he plays out inside
yeah you know yeah
i was even surprised after the third
round that it was the end of the fight
i was lost i was there like okay i have
my time you know
calm down and uh i think this basically
um
about the stupid fight i'm like calm
down you have all your time
and at the end of the fight i thought i
still have like around
yeah and it was the end of three rounds
man and that's where i like [ __ ] what's
going on
something something's wrong and uh
i'm like okay i can gather myself
figure out put together my [ __ ] and go
back there
and basically at that time man you kind
of hear
any kind of [ __ ] people doubting you
saying anything
about you do you pay attention to that
like social media
stuff like that it's not like something
that you can't pay attention
you you hear it you get it you just pay
attention of it
that's the most honest question i heard
i hear something no i don't listen to
them some people say
how can you know this but then how can
you not how can you not hear it
like this all over you you know i'll
tell you it's all over you feel it
at some point i'm like man i wish i
wasn't here
you know i mean you kind of like mess
with your mind you want to be unknown
by people like where and you see
somebody like hey friends this can i
have a picture you're ashamed of
yourself
i'm like why do you did you even want to
be when you want to be one picture with
me
like leave me alone you know but you
know you have to be that
you're trying to hide yeah the guy
you're embarrassed yeah you're right
yeah and uh
yeah but you know because you feel bad
about yourself your performance
everything you just feel like you're
nothing
uh if you wonder if you lost
no i mean that's what happened after the
last fight
you know and i was like back to back
lost
and he wasn't good and uh did you see
that fight mike
no so derek lewis is you know francis is
a knockout artist yeah and then derrick
lewis
definitely a knockout artist so the
public and the media is a bad fight he
was a stinker
his stinker yeah remember no disrespect
francis
they were supposed to knock each other
out in the first round they you know
it's this long drag
dragged out you know derek lewis had
like a back issue so he didn't pull the
trigger
francis was in his head so it was like
this weird fight
but and we were all expecting fireworks
so when that doesn't happen on that
magnitude of a fight
i'm sure you got a lot of [ __ ] that
makes sense name that too can i explain
that to you
this is in this world we live until we
have spirits right and then the spirits
are trying to
it's one spirit that says you're great
and that's what says you're not
and you go to these um no really you go
through these um
adversities in life and one of them wins
yeah so you know i mean one of them went
the the [ __ ] up guy or the good guy
but i think you were embarrassed right
because it was like all this pressure
there's no reason to be embarrassed
because it's all it's all internally
though mike you know yeah it's internal
people are not fighting no i know yeah
but you can't tell them oh you're not
fighting
you know yeah you're just getting hit
and you're taking it listen that's
that's where you're working dude you
were getting starbucks
that's what happened to the fighters
great fighter they feel humiliated they
kill themselves they stop
fighting and that's exactly i feel
really bad at that moment
i'm like damn i wish i was unknown
i wish i could hide like race
just get away of this and at some point
i'm like
[ __ ] either way what did that change i
always been
on the dock i always been in this
situation nobody like
truly believe in me yeah i mean yes
they believed at some point but at first
they were they weren't even there nobody
even believed yeah so
uh it's up to me now to do what i have
to do
maybe he it doesn't work but uh
at least did you ever fight derek again
no
no that might be but derek derek's now
on a win streak and then
if maybe you could give him a chance and
revenge that and make it yeah we have
fighting we have to do it
after john francis after john where
i'm not i would say every fighting yeah
making a [ __ ]
fight you know i wish i went after john
me too
everybody had the successful and
spectacular
makes jon even bigger make the whole
fight game even bigger
agree and john should have another one
more fight before him as well
so they could see what's going to happen
maybe you're not but
if one guy has earned a straight title
shot the heavyweight
title is john jones well i'm saying if
he wants to you want to make some extra
money before he fights you
yeah you know every time before i fight
a big fight
i always fight two guys to make what 10
million 20 million dollars for sure you
can fight
a guy for 160 million that's that box in
life though yeah like
in ufc there i always want to put in the
bank before i go for the big group if
you don't play like that
that's not gonna that's the [ __ ]
match yeah like like i want i want
holyfield i want holy feeling i want um
linux lewis this year i want both of
them this if i can get them both this
year
i [ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ] i won't do if i
box the exhibition with
tyson if i do that at least if i get
those two guys
hey this is a wrap i'm just gonna live
life yes sir and that's just exhibition
i'm gonna break all my
my professional true records yeah with
exhibitions
yeah do you do you feel like the baddest
man on the planet
because you know you when you were
fighting like everyone said you're the
best man on the planet
and then even now it carried over to
2020 22 on 21 where they go tyson fury's
the champ or anthony joshua's champ
that's the best mind on the planet
it's the best man on the planet because
he can fight fight just not box
france can box wrestle no no listen
you're the baddest man on the planet
because you beat the baddest man on the
planet and that's what he
beat the what's that black guy with the
russian name that was a bad [ __ ]
come on the black guy you knocked out in
the first round called the russian name
rival rosenstein yeah sure
that's from is he yeah that's from his
last name is russia
rosenstein yeah yes that's right yeah
he was the band he was an awesome
fighter too oh he's a bad man
it was like he was squatting a fly with
him
put the fight on put the fight on please
come on please we can do this bring up
what he did to curtis blades
blade one was sticky yeah but still bad
though man no
no no no you didn't see this one i could
tell you guys no i
i saw this one because francis threw
caution in the wind and just had no
respect that was too high then
everything happened
but you know you just took one though
god and you were so humble with
i i don't understand why he was talking
to him
what did he talk to me like that why did
he talk to you
he [ __ ] up man he knows what i do why
wouldn't he know
what i do i don't care he saw him why
would he do those things
yeah yeah the funniest thing is like he
called me out
and he was out there [ __ ] like i'm
gonna be the first one knocking
uh in ghana uh knocking out ingano
then i saw him i kind of like see myself
when i started i'm like
where guess what kid you don't know what
you're putting yourself into
and he was talking talking talking oh
yeah this one right here
oh he'd be knocking people yeah he'll
knock your dick in the dirt this cat
right here right
if i watch this watch this [ __ ] somebody
told god
oh oh oh oh my god
yeah you gave him a few extra oh listen
if i was with my manager customize my
training customer i was here
i liked the guy with eight seconds i
know what he said i didn't do it
perfectly for him the way he taught me
to do it he said listen
eight seconds he said listen that guy
was a little bit more experienced he
would have hit you
yeah you know i would never say that's
crazy but
really okay i'll practice to keep my
head down more yeah i'm saying to myself
i'm saying
eight seconds tonight i [ __ ] up in
eight seconds
when was the fight a couple of months
ago how was it last year last year
last year he just woke up this morning
[Laughter]
funny like at the win like um
i face him the first time i'll stare at
him like this
i saw a different guy it wasn't like the
guy was talking out there
you see like he's like [ __ ] what the
hell do i put myself
into that energy baby
it's too late no time to talk anymore
just time to fight and the next day uh
in the octagon
like i was a red corner so he'd get in
the octagon first
then i got in after and on my side was
looking at him
man he was cold like i'm like
did this guy did it guy uh even get one
more warm up or something
he was looking so bad you knew i'm like
yeah this is the moment whatever you
said you're gonna pay you know
you have to do it now yeah i have to see
that
but that's why listen maybe maybe and
god willing he was lucky that you were
swinging
like what maybe you did actually you
might have killed him but i was i was
very frustrated about that fight because
like
yeah because i was um expecting a fight
for so long and basically like i thought
i deserved a
title you know and then you know having
a fight
dealing with the fight with the ufc at
that moment was so hard to complicate
so like i get there i feel like that
fight
i i i took it as a slap on the face like
i'm like [ __ ] okay so like this is kind
of like
what i have to get okay so for me
he was like yeah i felt disrespected i
i'm not distracted
because i felt like for a long time you
weren't getting the they weren't
keeping you active and you're in your
prime right now i know that
i keep asking we keep asking for a fight
and they're like oh
let's wait for if this guy fired this
guy this play out like this
the steeper dc thing held up everything
he wasn't even on the topic at the time
yeah you know like okay we don't even
know what's going on we don't know what
happens check this out it's hard to deal
with this oh this guy's a good boxer
he's a monster yeah oh that's boom
fish is evil well obviously he's a tough
one too man
you hit him with the one on top of the
ear too yeah with the left and back
everybody heard it i didn't feel like i
heard him i'm like why do you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you why are you falling those are the
best punches sometimes
most of my fights when i throw a punch
and the guys out cause staff thought i
missed them yeah
yeah that's what's happening here i did
this just to like count
then if he went down i'm like okay
where i don't know what's happened but i
have this hold up yeah you're secure
yeah yeah her babies get some different
shoes get in there
what like what like when when you're
fighting uh
steep and you like he's dude he's like
this
it's not your job to stop you go till
the ref pulls you off yeah
herb needs to be a little closer no no
no hey
honestly i watched this fight and i saw
the hebden
action and i think this should be the uh
performance of the night
herb do you see how how fast he's
running i know we
like he was you know he was going uh
moving backward
and then after the action like you see
how fast
he's busting his brain like the guy the
guy was a notice you know that if some
his friends is touching him
don't let him touch you
wait until i have money for now i'm just
you like giving money to women giving
money to a woman these are great
questions
let's let's see if when i have money hey
brother listen we have enough to throw
around now no
yes yeah i'm not doing we are not doing
the same i'm not we are not doing the
same thing
business like you so listen hey hey
listen it's not the pay days you got
money yeah yeah
it's not accepted it's nothing to do
with you
40 000 a year i can make 40 000 a year
stretch out
yeah i bet now but when you were
fighting you were pretty loosey-goosey
with money right oh my god
elephant in the room but you know oh
[ __ ] that's why
that's what i'm
forgive me god why did you make me like
this why am i like this but let's get
back to you
i think you're awesome i think that's
great that
how do you manage money you have
accountants what do you do how do when
you want to listen
if you want to but if you want to go out
and buy um
let's say a car you say buy a
living room set what do you do a living
room set yeah do you do it yourself and
pick it out or you
call somebody think you'd be kind enough
to help me look for
a living room said how do you know i can
call somebody to hurt me for design
but i go up and pick it myself you know
yeah like somebody will help me for like
um
interior to design it how what would be
best with what
depending on what i like but i would be
out there myself
how nice they are when i was younger all
the time about those white tigers mike
forget that when i used to be young i
used to have survivors guys what i'm
doing all this [ __ ] like that [ __ ]
hundreds of thousands of
all this money online
he's not getting paid like the best man
yeah big dad well in a situation like
that you have to make your own
listen a guy like him know what a guy
like this guy can do
he can make his own organization they're
saying start his own fight
look i've been doing that you're
you know he he just got the belt so he
fights john he's getting paid he fights
john
you're not dude do you not john out
we're going sizzler i know like we're
all getting
chinchilla coats in six months sitting
back down here
and francis can buy all of his
chinchilla coats what's the promotion
um legends only leagues that's that's
mike's uh
listen an apprentice is legends only
league right
and it's no easy fights all the best
fighting the best
but you're my tyson yeah i don't i don't
listen
i don't look at it as mike tyson i look
at me this guy from brownsville that
lives in the sutter
the gutter it's a really disgusting kid
i don't look at me
this big superstar i'd never look at
myself that way because i would fail
that's true that's true that's true
that's like me
i fear i reset my goal every time when i
go back home and like
to go back where i was um like trying to
do even those jobs
even though i don't care about it
anymore but like trying to do it it fit
it
makes me remember like when where i was
there
you know like he refreshed my memory and
uh
just made me feel that so it helped me
like to
know exactly where i'm going then when i
came back in
the u.s i know what i'm coming here for
mike you know
i know he's used to work in san
francisco
before last year he was telling me this
but he doesn't know in a country like
this you could be
you could be your own um enterprise your
own business
you could swear and believe for yourself
that's why you're working instead of
someone else you know
you could do that here yeah y'all
marketing my
team my manager we are working on this
if i can do this stuff i'm not that
smart
if i can do this stuff brother you can
do it
but mike imagine i told you i want to
god food i want to guard fools
if i can do it anybody can but mike
imagine imagining your first title and
then doing this
like that's where francis is at you know
like he has so much more work to do
there's such big fights coming up oh
absolutely but he can't look at it
he has to believe that he's that person
that he has to that you say he has to be
he has to believe he's that person this
instant mm-hmm
right now he's the guy that those big
fights coming he's already beat those
guys
and his heart in his spirit but he got
put in the work to do it for sure
but you guys first have the power of
belief when you go back home francis
do they realize like what what type of
star you are
do they realize like kind of what your
fight purse is
they think like you have a bank you own
a bank yeah
but which is which is okay
uh because like yeah they feel uh they
realize
what you're doing and make it even
bigger i'm gonna tell you something like
uh in 2018 after i lost
against tp when i went back i feel like
i felt like
[ __ ] couldn't sleep even when i go to
i went to sleep i didn't want this uh
sun to rise the next day i felt like i
wanted
the day the night just last forever you
know
i couldn't look at myself feel very bad
at that moment
i'm like man at some point i'm like man
this is how you
find that that people uh suicide
i just took my phone and then went
online booking
first plane for cameron against and
guess what when i went in cameron
the welcome that i had there man like it
was crazy
they were so excited so happy so proud
and at some point i was still like
feeling bad about myself
yeah i'm like there was just like hey
charm welcome and everybody was going
crazy even
grammars who doesn't know anything about
fighting
and now i'm like listen guy uh i think
you might get
get something wrong here i lost i didn't
win that fight
i'm like we don't care you you want
everything like
where are you coming from to get there
like we we never had somebody there we
never even
expect somebody uh from us
we get there and you make it there you
represent us we make our surprise
obviously it didn't go your way but you
see you're still young and this i'm like
oh this is cool
i feel good i was such a fool for that
for the uh like i didn't want to come
back
yeah you might have like a nervous you
made it yeah i stayed there for like
five
five weeks then i came back here then
you know i have to get back some people
don't have expectations
yeah we have expectations and [ __ ]
that was crazy francis are there more
guys that look like you
walking the streets of canada oh yeah oh
you turn off them what are we in nigeria
and that's why they never did a push-up
in their life
they never did a push-up never walked
this you never ran unless they're
playing some sports
normal around the neighborhood and they
look like they're brick walls because
russians are taking over like mixed
martial arts and box and it's like if
you look at it the africans are because
you'll get because because
they have open housemen you yeah like
you guys are all the the
they have children they have opportunity
and in africa you have to see like
what africa is making with less than
nothing
sure you know like um we were talking
about like people walking around
push-ups i grew up without doing
anything as a sport
you know nothing i never do anything and
i believe that even now that i'm a ufc
charm i believe that there's still a lot
of people a ton of people out there
better than me
they don't just have opportunities
yeah you know so you have to look at the
uh
uh statistic you know how many african
fighters in the ufc
not a lot but there's some champs not
not a lot
for like a uh roster the ufc roster has
over 500 fighter 1 african
yeah less less than less than 20 african
in the ufc in seven division we have
tree belt
that means a lot they're taking that
meaning everything you have to look at
it like this
start the bridge you have to deal with
the adversity of life and sports because
adversity is going to make the week
weaker and the stronger stronger
and it's going to separate the two and
that's this is what life is really um
based on you know the survival of the
fittest
but don't you think francis like you you
know especially now
being the champ don't you think more
guys from your hometown are like [ __ ]
look at francis man
oh they started training oh they've been
like that for quite a while
started yeah since i got started there
is a lot of people out there believing
you don't believe that you're the best
because you put in the most work and you
trained and no one gave it to me
and not many people are going to work as
hard as you will be able to
accomplish what you accomplish and
they'll still be successful
you're one you had one of those rare
breeds of um
dedication where people really put in
the hard hard work
yeah and still and everybody we could
all still improve
yeah i could you like the prototype of
that
i agree with that but at the meantime i
know that there is a lot of people
uh i know my i know my hometown and my
country
and there's a lot of people out there
who probably put more work than me
and don't get the opportunity to
showcase that
you know like i don't consider
i i'm dedicated to what i want
i know like when i believe in something
i go for that doesn't matter what
doesn't matter what people believe or
not but there's a
lot of people out there who like
hard worker than me i believe so i don't
take this like
like granted i don't take this like oh
i'm the best worker in the world
you know i think at some point i enjoy
i'm just
are also grateful for the opportunity
and for the luck that i have
as well because there's a ton of people
that work even harder and they can even
assure
uh to have food when they're hungry
and that's how he's just out there if
i'm at ufc i do
i do a fight in africa you have three
african champions men
they should like why not do francis
versus jon jones in africa
do they have their walking paper do they
have their freedom papers
that's not that's not hard to get well
but
in order to even think this you need to
have walking papers
you know when you look at we look at
sports as an organization
it's a form of slavery or um enterprise
of the former slavery
we're all working for that cause they
hit that enough for we never have to
work again
you know the average person
that's their dream to never work again
yeah and then when they have that dream
they're gonna
be miserable not working but it's just
um
it's just this dream in our head that we
if we if we're working and we're
breaking our necks that we're slaves
you know to a certain degree that is
true but every athlete especially the
athlete
of his degree my degree we should own
ourselves we should we should suffer
get our ass kicked get knocked out or
knock people out
on our own benefits agree and nobody
should be taking our percentage
for our my cuts and our bruises they
take out
they take percentages so us getting beat
up it's crazy
and that's and that's why john jones
holding up yeah
i think holding out is a bad situation
if you're not making money and you're
holding out
your yourself suffering but not if
you're set like john is set he doesn't
need to fight
well listen um say if i was a guy like
that
and i'm on papers i'm fighting in
siberia i'm getting a check
somewhere i'm going somewhere i'm going
to the end
i'm going somewhere and somebody's going
to have to sue me in court but i'm
getting the check somewhere
i'm going to i'm not ufc i'm going to
wwf
i'm going to get a check somewhere i'm
not going to starve because somebody
else believe he has the carrot twins he
has me on the contract
i'm gonna i'm gonna but i don't think
he's good that fight he's gonna go
to the end he's gonna go to the fight
because the process will stop
he will stop in the process but then
yeah that's right that's
aware yeah yeah then they should be only
a lawyer should meet
i think um having managers are a joke
you should have either a lawyer a lawyer
a manager
of i my opinion for man the manager is
what
um glamorized cheerleader
pretty much what do you need a manager
for but you got a lawyer
why do you have two of them i have a
manager and a lawyer why am i paying
both of them to do the same
job no but i think you have a
as you said for from your experience i
think um
you you went to something really
different and really hard
and maybe uh how much you pay they
they take advantage on you but uh
sometimes i'm the poster boy i've taken
advantage of
yeah i think that's why you have your
smackdown i think that that's why that's
why you have they're really effective
you know sometimes you work with some
you get somebody
like working with whether it's a manager
or a coach
and then you feel like um at some point
you might even feel like they're under
pay why because the service how
uh they are involved in everything
coming your way how they are manifesting
his friend
you know now it's depend for the service
it depends on what the manager is doing
for you yeah for like you know what is
it
like we are in a two era very
different and a two different sport you
know
uh today we capitalize on like
building our own brand like having
sponsor you know we
we need that to to um
pay our bills as well because we don't
have as much
in the fighting uh like for fighting
fight check
so we need to build around we need to
manage our life
and there's a lot of things going on
that we can't we cannot manage it
ourselves so we definitely need somebody
around to help
us handle that to go out the um
hustle for us and that lawyer that's
that's what the manager be
lawyer is it like a lawyer always have
an official duty he always
tell you the truth lawyer is like he's
not gonna retire
lawyer take care of lego staff not all
the time though
i mean when it's not like there goes
stuff that's all you need is legal stuff
you know that's all you need in your
life is legal stuff and your trainer
well
i don't know let's say and i don't know
so let's say
and i'm sure they want to let's say they
want to make a movie about francis and
let's say paramount or universal comes
to francis
you don't want just a lawyer dealing
with it no no no no
no you don't have any experience on that
yeah
it's not his job you have to you have to
give everyone his own job
what kind of lawyer you have that
doesn't know about entertainment
are you paying this lawyer a full time
is it working for you
yeah okay guess what we don't have as
much money to pay lawyer full time
so we rather have a manager over a
lawyer
you're talking about it's two different
business mike
you can't just compare this it just
seems the same i use no oppression a
person's oppression and you fight it all
the same way
there's no i don't think you can find
like five uh
mma fighters in the world who can afford
to have like
a full-time lawyer no you can't find
that it'd be tough
again the world the world's just well
that's not possible it's this the fight
isn't
spending more money for for less like
it's
it's more cut than what you you should
get like his personal like
30 40 mail mike because if you tell the
lawyer that okay you're working for me
full time from
10 percent he can't work for you i'm
like [ __ ] you you know
because your money is not that big
i think i'm struggling
of managers and lawyers mike are
different because you're a person like
you're talking about the 90s what france
is doing building this empire this brand
it's just
he's almost in the fight entertainment
business now it's just a different
animal and how many zero on your picture
i see a [ __ ] superstar and when i see
everyone
i see a [ __ ] that could pay his
[ __ ] dinner bill
and help his friends out too that's what
i say
the real question is my paycheck goes
with that can i afford that i can't
afford it how many more
how many fights do you have on the
contract well
um no much but more than two
round there right now that's kind of
like oh my gosh fight
i'm a champion now i have extension and
everything so it's kind of like six
months you can fight two fights in six
months they won't let them fight that
that early huh well a year you get two
fights in the year right
i had 15 fights in one year as a pro
yeah yeah
that means 15 dudes we're getting [ __ ]
up about state actors my state
act seemed but it's not up to him like
because the ufc controls his narrative
so like
for the longest time he was ready to go
and they couldn't get him fights
so that's what what you saw that assault
and rosenstew that was his frustration
yeah because they wouldn't give him a
fight i have like two fights for almost
two years
i wanted when you're in contract you
can't fight nowhere else no
no it's exclusive and one of the one
things that makes the ufc
special and where they're at is their
contracts are ear tight man they have
the best lawyers
so if you try going somewhere else
you're lawyers ah
not the manager they have horrible they
have horrible managers yeah
this is the problem this is the problem
you got sucky man
you can't afford a lawyer this is the
difference this is
all the differences i can't remember
when i didn't have a lawyer even when i
was
of course you had with my team you had
money for that having
mike you had two white tigers you had
money for that
you got one of them too that's what i'm
saying
you are giving uh royal royce away yes i
am oh okay
we are talking about two different
stories away yeah it does
like we don't feel like we are even
related to your
story when it comes to money we are not
even related different
you know different atmosphere we will
just take we will just carry your back
man i don't know anybody poor to me
until i went to mexico
really nobody's poor to me [ __ ] when
you're talking about when you're coming
up
yeah in brownsville [ __ ] no
but francis has seen that too though you
know
there's similar stories there ooh
like talking about a monster
you start talking about
francis don't don't you think the ufc is
going to start kind of doubling down on
africa
don't wouldn't be as far as a business
plan you know they're all about money
and you look at the
on tap talent there you look at the the
three stars between
usmen style bender and you which are the
three faces of the ufc
all african i mean i uh that's what we
all believe
you know we're building an organization
for african fighters where they have
their rights
and they're not slaves to the
organization you're not seeing that
that's what i see when you put you all
together
rights african rights violation unit
you think africa should start their own
league mike i think they should do it
over here but somebody should represent
them
they should have a lawyer not a manager
maybe represent them of course like when
it comes to legal
legal stuff yeah you need to he needs a
lawyer yeah but you know see a guy like
me i need him
to teach me how to live my life don't
touch that person don't touch this don't
i need a lawyer i don't know who your
lawyer is man they sound lit as [ __ ]
i need them you know i need them well
back in the day you probably need one
mate like really
no no exactly back in the day i was
action
i'm really just thought now like one of
the nice guys i know now
yeah i'm very happy to be that guy now
yeah thank god
i have a commercial you saw my
commercial mike lemonades no i have a
[ __ ] commercial since pepsi that must
be like 40 years since they gave me a
commercial
you know i got a commercial who nobody
saw my commercial yeah
thank you [ __ ] your voice saw it
what was it i don't
i don't really watch tv it's on [ __ ]
it's all over yeah yeah i saw it on
cable yeah
people watch cable baby [ __ ] francis
needs a commercial
that's what i'm talking about oh you did
a ufc toyo tire commercial right
yeah i do the pedo stuff oh dope i do
the
journey legion mitsubishi in las vegas
love it
so it's like and where's home francis
right now where's home
las vegas las vegas that's where you
need to live but listen
legends only league not only when our
fighters come to us you know they only
they don't even know they're in the
fight where we will have them they will
also have inside
agents where they get roles on
television commercials these are
going to make them superstars when we
introduce them to the public normally
the public
is introduced to the fighter but we're
going to introduce the fighter to the
public
but if they're but if they're legends
mike that they're kind of we are not
most of them will be gotcha everything's
pretty much pay-per-view but still we
have um
we have a platform for just um saturday
night fight yeah fights
and stuff that sounds cool i talked to
the guys
um yesterday but this is this has never
been done before
this is this is almost like mo time when
we come we bring the fighters in
we clean them the [ __ ] up we put them on
scene we let the whole world evaluate
them
and then they're in the ring so they
already have a fan base people are aware
of them
that's almost like really old school
stuff cleaning kids up
um having teaching them i'm not gonna
teach anybody to eat but you just
yeah setting them up in the game
teaching them the game having their own
account
mike what do you think about uh frank
like a lot of guys we hear especially in
the ufc go
i want to i want a shot at boxing i want
to i want to see how i do in boxing
usually it's a bad idea
but when francis goes oh i'd like to
shot in boxing like say him versus tyson
fury
that's one of the fights where i'm like
i'm kind of down for that well that
would be pretty interesting
especially after people see him learn
how to box
you know he has to put him in there with
guys who are very loose and it's very
difficult to hit
he's not going to be able to use his his
weight use your elbow but you can't use
your knees
his kicks are coming along but he's
boxing yes but you need to he's got to
make because fighters are interesting
fighters only got to worry about punches
so they see the punch and they know
where to punch
they know you can only punch straight
round up or over
and they anticipate boxing's just off
the [ __ ] chain
weird you're in there fighting the guy
you can't hit and you're truly trying to
hurt him and you can't hit him
yeah francis is that something you
you're open to
boxing yeah oh definition i mean i have
to
you know um boxing was my
my dream for so long but uh i didn't
have an opportunity
until the first opportunity that i had
was the ufc and then i'm like okay
you you don't you don't let you don't
let the opportunity like that on the
table yeah you know why you don't why
you don't have something you make money
faster and also your
name so at some point i'm definitely
going to do boxing
did you hear he's controlling boxing you
control your own destiny
yeah no one else i cannot do that it
depends
where he's at like let's say he beats
john and then gets on the mic and does a
hot promo to fight tyson fury
if he's still under contract like conor
was when he fought floyd
the ufc dana is going to get a piece of
his under contract or on
no free agent are going to do boxing
free agents
both are going to do i think it has to
happen
because there's nothing that we can't i
can deal with now if they take boxing
away
out of it yeah yeah so that's very i
would love to see it man
i want to train i want to put them on
that bag
it's not just about like do you have to
do things like you feel
things that you love things that you
like and doing boxing
is something that man i had i had this
dream i was like 12 years old to like
become a
boxer in my life and that's the only
thing that i i was like uh
excited about it so uh down the road
i uh crossed path with the image with
mma was always
has been great with me but
i still have to do this thing check that
out you have to
check that i would go out there and like
fail it for
for the high level yeah you listen for
me as a fan you know i'd love to see
fight john in africa
i'd love to see fight tyson fury
whenever that happens i'd love
now that mma is legalizing france i'd
love to see ufc in france
john africa no ju fighting john john
johnson
john jones i don't know john africa it
sounds dope
i think they can i think they can
recreate rainbow in the jungle
i mean that's the idea that would be
something dope oh and i'm born in the
jungle
yes and i'm definitely gonna be part of
on that one
yeah you'll be the face of it my man pat
rambo in the jungle
you know i wish i wish they'd do it uh
pretty close soon like maybe something
with jones or something
but man we're gonna we're gonna recreate
rainbow in the jungle that's something
a peak you know and now that uh african
is
stands as a figure of combat sport as
well
you know we have to go back to that
agree yeah how much you have to get to
be ready for that matter how much
charity you can do for africa they won't
have to come out their purse either
yeah he does a lot of things oh he's a
ton of charity yeah yeah
and if you fought it with jon jones and
you could build the school to build a
house will also impact the economy yes
you know in that department basically
like fighting
like you're going to start you're going
to see like more and more
gym grow from i would be willing to bend
the next year
there's a ufc gym with your face on it
out in cameroon
well
there is a lot of team which is just up
to the ufc i know man
yeah so hey can you picture me saying
this no i don't know how to see
i bought it right here how is my life my
liver died today
it's up to this guy if i'm going to eat
today it's up to this guy if i'm going
to talk to you today
yeah no but here you are in order to
have a ufc gym
it's up to the ufc yeah you know i'm
compassionate and i am a strong believer
in humanity
and i don't see none of that here when
we talk about the human beings in the
ufc
i'm just saying i don't know i'm a
stupid i don't know what you're not
doing
i don't know but you do know the fight
game mike so when you talk
you know it's i don't know i really
don't know like i win game i know the
human game
you know the human game you know the
fight game but you could like you know
you had dana on the show
if you would ask him i do you i know you
had dana on the show yeah
you could ask him you know you know he's
the one who holds
yeah this man yeah yeah i could talk
today about that
but they didn't need these guys to
confront him and say anything i'm dying
that yeah
i have their handouts you know
that's i was that way with don king you
know me and don't get a friend now but i
had to learn
i had to learn and now i'm doing what
dexter is but
i'm not a promoter i've never called
myself a promoter
but um i'm treating people fair yeah
well that's all we want for francis
to fight for fear fairness is not given
to us
that's true fairness is not given well i
think that's it
and i love everybody love you guys this
hot boxing with mike tyson
that's the champ the baddest man on the
planet francis
in ghana the last time i was here you
called me on crown champ
you entitled me on crown champion yeah
but now i'm a crown charm but listen
now you're going to be the longest
reigning crown champion
no but listen with a guy like you man
you're so humble and stuff
he's the best and when i was champion i
dare you to even
think about challenging me you know i
i've learned so much as meeting you i've
learned a lot about humbleness
it's really so awesome thank you so
happy for your success yeah i appreciate
you guys having me here man yes
[Music]
mike tyson raves in full bloom have
captured the art of fighting
the hollywood reporter says it's mallet
meet scorcese
[Applause]
in full bloom available now on amazon
prime video
you